If today felt like it had a bit
of an orange glaze cast over it,
that's because
it was the birthday
of evil James Spader character
Donald Trump.
-Ugh.
-Yes, Donald turned 70 today,
although his hair
only turned six.
Uh... but what do you get
for the man who had everything,
lost everything, got everything
again, lost everything again,
and is now close to becoming
the leader of the free world?
-(audience boos)
-Well...
I... I-I didn't do it.
Uh... uh, you got to just
check Amazon, you guys.
I would like you to give me as
many items that you might find
on Donald Trump's Amazon
wishlist as you can
in 60 seconds.
And begin. Matteo.
Father-daughter porn.
Points. Grace.
Child leash for Ivanka.
Reluctant hand job
from Chris Christie.
Points. Mamrie.
A soda stream.
It doesn't affect anything,
it's just a great product.
Yeah, it's a great gift.
It's a great gift. Mamrie.
Uh, those Hulk hands painted
orange to hide his tiny hands.
All right, points. Yeah. Matteo.
The Rosie O'Donnell Show
in box set.
All right, points.
Mamrie.
Uh, that hug from his father
he never got,
which is why we're in this
(bleep) show to begin with.
Okay, points.